All right, I'm ready. Go ahead.
Ask me anything.
You know me. I'm an open book.
When's the last time
you saw him?
I'm insulted by the premise
of that question.
When was the last time
you saw Trump?
I haven't seen him.
I saw daddy on the tape.
Same as everyone else.
The deposition tape.
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
We have other copies of that.
He vanished.
Donald Trump has been missing
since 2024, six years now.
He left. He's gone.
He took the midnight bus
to Georgetown. Like the song.
When was the beginning
of the end?
Well, I guess it was 2018 when
the Democrats took the House
and made Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez the speaker.
And chair of ways and means.
And oversight of banking
in foreign affairs.
And starting pitcher
on the softball team.
The new Democratic led congress
announcing their intentions
to file articles of impeachment.
It was scary.
Everyone was talking
about impeachment
because of what Cohen told them,
and because of what
Eric told them,
and because of what I told them,
and because of what
Melania told them,
and because of
what Ivanka told them,
because of what Jared told them.
This was different than
with Muller,
because Cortez was, well-
She was hot.
She was like Cheetah Rivera
with subpoena power.
I mean, the President got
his wires crossed.
Speaker Ocasio-Cortez is
a very treacherous,
beautiful, un-American, lovely,
dishonest, luscious-
Dad was thinking when his dick,
and his dick didn't work
anymore.